طفله تبلغ من العمر 16 اعوام تنقذ حياه
والدتها من خلال طلب المساعده باستخدام
اليكسا الطفله دارسي كانت تعلم منذ صغرها
ان والدتها تعاني من مشكله في القلب
ويمكنها طلب المساعده عبر اليكسا طبعا
بالفعل استخدمت دورسي المساعده ذكيه
المساعده الذكيه اليكسا مرتين لاطلاق
ناقوس الخطر عندما كانت والدتها البالغه
من العمر 27 عاما مريضه وفي الواقع الام
قامت باعداد اليكسا بحيث تتحول الى اداه
للنجاه بس خلينا نوضح شو هي اليكسا اليكسا
جهاز صغير انا عندي واحد في البيت كده كره
صغيره
تشتغل على على الواي فاي يعني وتقدرين
يعني تتصلين فيها من خلالها في البيت تلعب
ميوزك سعرها
على حسب بس هو الفكره انه او برايي بانه
برافو على الاهل اللي علموا هذه الطفله
تكون يعني قد المسؤوليه وانها تطلب يعني
تطلب مساعده هي فقط قالت اليكسا call هيلب
وقدرت انها تنقذ امها من خلال هاي الجمله
يعني هي بطله صغيره وانها برضه والديها
يعني كل الاحترام لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات